thank you thank well
this is this is it folks thank you
everybody for coming out so early this
morning
in only a couple of hours I will be in
Balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader the Baton will
be handed over in what does unexpectedly
turned out to be a relay race they
changed the rules halfway through but
never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in Europe and never
forget 70 of the entire population got a
dose within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government people
Ukrainian Armed Forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest European War for
80 years and because of the speed need
an urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from July last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the naysayers we have and will
continue
to have that economic strength to give
people the cash they need to get through
this energy crisis that has been caused
by Putin's vicious walk
I know the nun that Liz
Trust and this compassionate
conservative government will do
everything we can to get people through
this crisis and this country will endure
it and we will win and if Putin thinks
that he can succeed by blackmailing or
bullying the British people then he is
utterly deluded and the reason we will
have those funds now and in the future
is because we conservatives understand
the vital symmetry between government
action and free market capitalist
private sector Enterprise we're
delivering on those huge Manifesto
commitments making streets safer
neighborhood crime down 38 in the last
three years 13 790 more police on the
streets building more hospitals and yes
we will have 50 000 more nurses by the
end of the decade and 40 more hospitals
by the end of fifty thousand nurses by
the end of this Parliament I should say
40 new hospitals by the end of the
decade putting record funding into our
our schools and into Teachers Pay giving
everybody over 18 a lifetime skills
guaranteed so they can keep upskilling
throughout their lives three new
High-Speed Rail lines three including
Northern Powerhouse Road colossal Road
Prague programs from the pennines at De
Cornwall the rollout of gigabit
Broadband up over the last three years I
am proud to say since you were kind
enough to elect me from seven percent of
our country's premises having gigabit
Broadband to 70 today and we're of
course providing the short and the long
term solutions for our energy needs and
not just using more of our own domestic
hydrocarbons but going up by 2030 to 50
gigawatts of wind power that is half uh
this country's energy electricity needs
from offshore wind alone a new nuclear
reactor every year and looking at what
is happening in this country the changes
that are taking place that is why
private sector in investment is flooding
in more private sector more venture
capital investment than China itself
more billion pound tech companies
sprouting here in the UK but in France
Germany and Israel combined and as a
result unemployment as I leave Office
Unemployment down to lows not seen since
I was about 10 years old and bouncing
around on a space Hopper my friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that I am now like one of
those booster Rockets
that has fulfilled its function and I
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
Pacific
like Cincinnati
will be offering this government nothing
but the most fervent support
this is
I'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy this is a tough time for
families up and down the country we can
and we will get through it and we will
come out stronger the other side but I
say to my fellow conservatives it's time
for politics to be over folks it's time
for us all to get behind Liz truss and
her team and her program and deliver for
the people of this country because that
is what the people of this country want
that's what they need and that's what
they deserve
I'm proud to have discharged the
promises I made to my party when are you
kind enough to choose me winning the
biggest majority since 1987 the biggest
share of the vote since 1979 delivering
brexit delivering our Manifesto
commitments including by the way
including social care reforming social
care helping people up and down the
country ensuring that Britain is once
again Standing Tall in the world
speaking with Clarity and Authority from
Ukraine to the orcas pact with America
and Australia because we are one whole
and entire United Kingdom whose
diplomats Security Services and Armed
Forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as I believe I as I leave I believe our
Union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody behind me in this
building thank you to all of you in
government uh thank you everybody who's
helped look after me in my family over
the last three years including including
Dylan the dog
and I just say to my body of Dylan and
Larry can put behind them their
occasional difficulties then so can the
conservative body
above all thanks to you and the British
people to the voters for giving me the
chance to serve all of you
who works so tirelessly together
to beat kovid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
Paving Paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations and I will be supporting Liz
truss and the new government every step
of the way thank you all very much thank
you and goodbye thank you
[Applause]
okay